pendant l'été nous poursuivons notre
série de découvertes de la région ce
soir rencontre avec un personnage
insolite l'éclusé du canal saint martin
il gère le trafic parisien les péniches
les bateaux mouches ou la navigation de
plaisance portrait réalisé par isabelle
dupont et didier morel
à l'heure où paris s'éveille le canal
saint-martin sommeille encore ce n'est
qu'à 8 heures précises couvre les
écluses celle du temple est le domaine
d'antoine bûcher j'ai travaillé aussi
bien sur le canal saint martin le canal
seine pendant six ans sur le canal
saint-denis et le reste du temps sur
canal saint martin tout d'abord il va
falloir que je j'en aime tous les
détritus ce tout ce qui se trouve comme
corps étranger sur l'eau et préparer mon
équipe pour pouvoir travailler dans les
bonnes conditions
quatre à cinq fois par jour les
éclusiers voit défiler les bateaux de
touristes qui parcourt le canal saint
martin entre bastille et la villette
quatre kilomètre et demi en plein paris
compte fait par le passage de neuf
écluses au temple ses six mètres de
dénivelé qu'antoine fait franchir aux
habitués en un petit quart d'heure
capitte de manivelle comme avant c'est
juste les deux bouts pour être au niveau
c'était beaucoup plus dur que maintenant
qu'elle a fallait avoir des gros bras à
la fin de la journée on avait vraiment
mal et si le canal ignore les
embouteillages il arrive pourtant qu'on
se bouscule au portillon
zilla il arrive en cela il est dû à la
demie l'ag le canotier qui va arriver et
rusé alex du temps j'ai un petit
plaisanciers qui va attendre à ce que le
canadien c'est un bateau prioritaire
après ces deux bateaux jouer un bateau
qui se trouve qu'il est entrain
d'excusés à l'éclusé nationale c'est une
péniche de blé c'est sous la partie
souterraine du canal longue de 2 km que
les bateaux non prioritaires péniche et
plaisanciers attendent leur tour
fait quand même 12 mois 87 mardi les
petits plaisanciers
depuis sa construction en 1825 le plus
parisien des canaux à conserver son
atmosphère le seul ou l'automatisation
n'a pas remplacé les hommes où l'on se
raconte encore des histoires entre
mariniers et éclusiers
vous descendiez caen demain cet après
midi
demain à belgrade je serais pas là ah
non je me repose
si vous me voyez c'est en vélo j'ai pas
de bateau là jusqu'à 2h45 je vais
appeler pour être tranquille si j'ai
plein de petits plaisanciers
loin de la martinique antoine le
brigadier des excuses s'est reconstitué
au près du canal un univers aquatique où
nous n'avions que des marins d'eau douce